oh i can't turn my back on the eye  welcome back to the things by the end of  descendants 3  mal got her happy ending or did she what  if life with king ben  turned out to be too boring for the vk  we're picturing what it would be like if  mal  ditched the beast's son and decided to  marry harry hook instead  these two villain kids had chemistry and  their spark got reignited when the  barrier between auradon and the isle of  the lost  came down while working with harry and  the other bks to create a new united  land  mal remembered how much she loved  hanging with the pirate  so much so she ditched her crown as  queen of aradon and became the pirate  crew's latest recruit  bad luck benny boo  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  your love is so sweet  so put it on  can me take it higher what do you desire  let me see that fire fire hey  [Music]  me  [Music]  let me see that fire fire  [Music]  i is  got me so excited  [Music]  let me